okay I want you to do something for me
now find your deepest voice saying
always or worse well you did that well
in the movie she's actually possessed
during the movie and it was more like a
documentary style yeah full on like a
method actress possession how did you
shed the character then after are you
still possessed I'm totally Sofala are
you yeah and Henry Henry Thomas actually
tried exercise yeah cuz he's an ordained
priest yes and I had to go on the
treadmill for a couple hours exorcise
the demon guys I want to rename this
movie whoa EG origin of love oh there's
so many love stories going on in this i
as a female really appreciated that that
it didn't just go straight to the war I
cared about the two of you I mean I
think that was one of the big
attractions to the to the script because
the director wanted to invest time and
building these relationships there's a
lot of chemistry thank you I mean oh
heck yes in la soon really i thought was
interesting about is like a very
unconventional love story and not i mean
he's a priest and I'm llamado and
there's this relationship developing
that's very possibly inappropriate or
it's a big theme for the whole film now
it's like everything is forbidden we
just write cousin right so you are you
less likely now that you've done this
film to like indulge in the supernatural
absolutely i guarantee i does i mean i
had to go home at night and like try to
wind it down and i go to bed it was
really hard after i went to the
screening my light was flickering
outside my house my key wouldn't work in
my door these things only happen right
after you've seen this is what i'm
saying that yeah I Gnaeus thing happened
to ya like
yes
you